grab your hottest cat suit and pucker up
because it's time to save Sheryl on this
week Sweetwater secret hello gorgeous
River babes
I'm your host Liana Galera and this is
your Sweetwater secrets after-show for
episode 217 chapter 30 the noose
tightens now today I'll be spilling
exclusive scoop for Madeline Peck about
Cheryl and Toni's big moment and her
hilarious behind-the-scenes secrets are
snot something you want to miss that'll
make sense later
plus if you've ever wondered if it would
be awkward for FP and Alice to date well
jugg had a Betty ercel together yeah
well I asked that very question to
matron Amick and Skeet Ulrich and their
answers are priceless but first it's
time to quickly catch you up on the
biggest headlines of the week in the
blue and gold breakdown with Cheryl
locked away and doing manual labor and
the sisters of quiet mercy super secret
gay conversion wing Tony and Veronica
decided to confront Penelope and demand
the truth about their maa friend
now after discovering that Cheryl was
the one who actually put the pig's heart
in Josie's Locker miss McCoy said no
thanks to the rescue mission I'm out you
guys and it was up to Ronnie and Tony to
break her out and looking fabulous while
doing it here to rescue you meanwhile
things with the Coopers got even crazier
as authorities discovered the car that
Betty and Jughead not so successfully
dumped in the lake they found it
turns out the car belonged to the dead
man's ex-girlfriend Darla and chick was
stupid enough to call her up and invite
her over to the Cooper household why
would you do that now Darla blackmailed
the Coopers and demanded $10,000 to keep
quiet about her boos dead body
but when Betty handed over the cash
Darla refused to leave luckily it was
the serpent's to the rescue again and
Alice finally did the unthinkable you're
not going to spend another night here
and lastly Hiram's mobster friends
returned to town and for some reason
Archie took it upon himself to gather up
a bunch of teenagers to send the
dangerous men a message
you should leave before it's too late I
can't and to thank him for his services
Hiram gave Archie a car because sure why
not but now it's time to focus on the
thing that brought me the most amount of
joy in this episode in this week's seven
seconds in heaven
after weeks of planting the seed and
nurturing this potential new ship Cheryl
and Toni's romance has finally blossomed
and Shoni sealed it with a kiss who
needs a knight in shining armor when you
can have a princess in a sultry cat suit
we search each and every damn room until
we find her now I know all you Shoni
fans are just as excited as I am about
this relationship revelation so when I
caught up with Madeline Pecha PaleyFest
this weekend we talked all about this
milestone moment and the hilarious onset
truth about that sweet kiss take a look
we got our show many kids talk to me
about filming that scene with Vanessa
with the projector it was beautiful a
really funny story so I'm like sobbing
in that scene before she comes right
it's this is so disgusting it's not
coming out of my nose and I didn't have
time to wipe it so this girl was eat
like eating mice not like it was in her
mouth and after every take I'd be like
sorry she was like that's what friends
are for
good pick we're best friends because
otherwise I think she would disown me at
this point and that's funny because you
guys are best friends in real life so
what's it like kissing your best friend
I mean it's less weird than kissing
someone you don't know I mean I'd rather
kiss my best friend then kiss some
random guy I don't know I just dismiss
buried more comfortable because we were
like we laughed about it for a second
they're like great let's do it and now
it's not weird at all yeah yeah
I love that oh I love them and I don't
know about you guys but I would kiss my
best friend but I don't think I'd eat
her snot let's move on to hisses and
kisses shall we all right first off
hisses - Archie oh my goodness red I do
not even know what to do with you
anymore
not only did he skip his father's
mayoral announcement but he also kept
weaseling his way into Hiram's problems
just because you won an arm wrestling
match and started up the black circle
new that doesn't mean that you're tough
enough to stand up to a bunch of
mobsters and
taken seriously you nearly had us there
red this is tyre lodge for the simple
fact that I'm tired of you and you and
your mobster drama are taking away so
much screen time from the characters
that I actually care about
no more chill like these guys hisses -
Penelope blossom for twisting the truth
and showing Josie Cheryl's drawings of
the two of them oh my god
true Cheryl may have taken her crush a
bit too far in the past but no one
deserves that kind of punishment hisses
- bug heads short-lived stint as roomies
and lastly hisses - chick for bringing
life-threatening chaos into the cooper
home again and continuing his streak as
being the worst character on TV GE chick
have ever actually been helpful in any
way as for kisses that one is going
straight to Nana rose for sparking Tony
and Ronnie's quest to save Cheryl and
for being reason that we now know that
Tony's full name is Antoinette topaz so
- Nancy
kisses to Tony and Cheryl's now iconic
kiss and to Tony and Veronica's
ridiculously sexy rescue outfits to
quote my coworker Brice and ER nothing
scares nuns more than underage cleavage
I can't remember anything other than
what I'm looking at right now kisses -
Alice were finally realizing that chick
is useless and for promptly yet politely
kicking him out of the house
oh and oh so many kisses to Alice for
re-embrace in her serpent past and
showing up at FPS doorstep are you guys
hoping for more phallus yeah me too so
my last kiss is going to you because
I've got a special treat for all of you
here's what matron Amick and Skeet
Ulrich had to tell me about what really
happened behind closed doors with FP and
Alice she happens to show up at
somebody's doorstep to get a little
something-something what's happening
between that mansion love serpent love
maybe in a trailer deep conversations
obviously just just talk they just talk
sit around and drink coffee dream with
me a little bit what do you think that
SP and Alice were like as kids as a
couple oh they were wild I think they
were like the original Sid Nancy I mean
those two on the town she was writing on
the back of his motorcycle sometimes she
was driving and he was writing on the
back of her motorcycle you know is there
I mean all that sort of started
developing early in the first season at
table reads we're like you know we just
joke around about what if what if and
then I sort of took off she's a blast so
that makes it really easy you know it's
fun to imagine what their history was
and I think certainly FB is probably the
only one that can keep her in line yeah
so if Alison FC began dating
yeah and Betty and Jughead are dating
awkward is that weird
um it's a bit awkward but nobody's
related yeah so you know I think it
would be kind of funny to see the four
of them like coming to the breakfast
table in the morning and how awkward
that would be the height morning height
morning orange juice sure you know
Ashley toes we know how much Alice loves
her breakfast so right yes and she would
she put our full spread curve for the
two couples awkward yeah I think that's
pretty weird but I think that's what the
show likes to embrace is some things
that are a little off what do you think
rubber babes would that be awkward you
know the drill hit the comments with
your thoughts and then spill your top
hisses and kisses of the episode plus
I'm dying to know what you all think
about Madeline's snot tastic
story about Shoney's first kiss please
give this video a like hit subscribe so
you never miss an episode of Sweetwater
secrets and then be sure to be following
my Twitter page because I'm going to be
dropping additional interviews with the
Riverdale cast and you won't want to
miss it now I'll see you in a couple
weeks for the big musical episode river
babes bye bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]